stéphane le foll le ministre de
l'agriculture et le porte parole du
gouvernement est l'invité de preuves par
3 bonsoir merci d'être avec nous avec
karine perret de l' agence france presse
avec perrine tarneaud de public sénat
est toujours en partenariat
comme chaque semaine avec dailymotion
françois hollande a donc abattu sa carte
de france ramenée à 14 régions mais
manuel valls précise dans la physique
dans la foulée que rien n'est figé alors
est-ce que ça n'aggravent pas le
sentiment d'un préparation
d'improvisation non la carte qui est
proposée par le président de la
république
elle est le point de départ qui est fixé
dans un débat qui a duré déjà depuis des
années je suis ici au sénat en
particulier où tout le monde à
revendiquer à proposer des regroupements
une réorganisation des taux s'est
tranché appartiendrait à un débat qui
s'engagera dans les assemblées et en
particulier ici au sénat et je les dis
je vais le dire ce soir le projet de loi
les deux projets de loi qui seront
présentées à la fois sur la carte sur
les élections et leur mode et sur les
compétences seront présentées au conseil
des ministres le 18 juin quand on
connaît maintenant briller on devait
tout de suite après il y aura des bas
mais qu'est-ce qui peut encore bouger
par exemple puisque ça n'est pas figé
donc le par exemple le nombre de régions
il peut encore non c est ce qu il peut
bouger on le sait il ne peut y avoir des
choix qui peuvent être exprimés s'il y a
un large consensus qui peut corriger ici
ou là des choix qui ont été proposées
mais globalement il ya deux principes
qui ont été fixés ont regroupé région et
on est démonté le pas voilà pour ça non
pas d'augmentation est fortement sur
seulement de l'antique sur ces deux
principes après voilà il ya une
proposition qui a été faite en tout cas
il était absolument nécessaire de mettre
un terme à ce sempiternel sempiternel
débat qui n'a jamais débouché
donc voilà le président de la république
a pris ses responsabilités
que savait ce que disent les psys away
sur les injonctions contradictoires
c'est ce qui est pire dans l'éducation
des enfants non mais on a quand même là
le chef de l'état a jugé paradoxal
quelquefois sécher et là on a le chef de
l'état donc qui tranchent difficilement
apparemment un mais
six des vingt ans que ça dure si c'est
qu'il y avait quelques régions et
c'était difficile il l'a fait il se
présente en tous les cas et ce sont ses
termes comme l'architecte d'une france
moderniser mais juste derrière il ya
premier ministre qui passe et qui lui
annonce la concertation donc d'un côté
les frères sa brûlante et la
concertation
on peut pas dire ça j'étais là j'étais
en face de lui il a dit ya maintenant
une étape qui est franchie
il ya bien sûr un débat dans les
assemblées qui peut faire évoluer les
choses
il n'a pas dit que ce qui a été mis sur
la table était fait pour être remis en
cause c'est pas ça qui l'a dit c'est pas
vrai il ya bien inscrit son discours
dans la proposition qui était fait et
aussi bien sûr dans le fait qu'après
avoir beaucoup discuté beaucoup écouté
il ya le parlement qui nous font bien
simple quand même se poser la question
sur ce qui peut encore bouger parce que
ça a bougé jusqu'au dernier moment avec
au fil des des coups de téléphone
notamment passé par le chef de l'état
pour le sort des pays de la loire ça a
donné lieu à d'incroyables variations 1
pourquoi ça n'a pas été possible de
satisfaire tout le monde à la fois
ségolène royal et jean marc ayrault non
utilisés c'est des sujets qui sont
beaucoup plus compliquées que les noms
que vous avez évoquées on est sur des
sujets qui sont avec des engagements
pour le moyen et le long terme avec des
choix vous savez en particulier sur la
la bretagne kiziki qui sont liés ou qui
peuvent être liés certains arguments à
l'idée que un départements la
loire-atlantique en l'occurrence
pourrait être attaché la bretagne
sachant qu'à partir de là on sait pas ce
qui se passerait peignoir je vois c'est
que son choix s'était pas sain mais
c'est pas ça c'est que dans un moment où
il faut trancher
il faut le faire avec la volonté de
réussir et de mettre sur la table chacun
devant ses responsabilités
et là il ya un débat qui s'engage mais
il ya surtout une étape majeure qui a
été franchi sur un débat je le dis qui
dure depuis 20 ans jean pierre raffarin
dénonce des décisions et une politique
au fil de l'eau mais si je regardais les
cartes qu'a proposé jean pierre raffarin
je vois pas pourquoi aujourd'hui jean
pierre raffarin ferai comme si ils
découvraient ce qu'il a lui-même un jour
proposé pour
fouras qu'est ce qui se passe on connaît
ça par coeur c'est pas le fond qui est
discutée la preuve c'est que jean pierre
raffarin était a commis un rapport avec
monsieur krattinger qui reprenait les
objectifs de manière très claire mais
oui mais parce qu'on fait de la
politique et on essaye de la faire quand
on est pas sur le fond on l'a fait sur
la forme en soi filles en vo accuse de
petits arrangements politiciens effets
de la politique aussi oui je crois qu'il
fait de la politique politicienne mais
chacun a fait de la politique mais on a
des responsabilités
on peut avoir des arguments qui sont
évoquées par certains jeux le contredit
pas ce que c'est les arguments
politiciens pour avoir des vrais débats
sur le fond et un sur des vraies
questions c'est pas ça tout simplement
on dit à une question de méthode
pourquoi parce qu'on veut pas discuter
du fond parce que que ce soit françois
fillon ou que ça soit jean pierre
raffarin
ils ont à plusieurs reprises proposé ce
qui est sur la table aujourd'hui à leurs
questions politiciennes est ce que vous
espérez avec cette réforme amortir un
éventuel nouveau contrecoup électorale
lors des élections régionales fin 2015
que vous rendez compte que vous ramenez
une réforme comme celle là non il y en a
c'est une gestion c'est une question
mais je vais vous répondre justement
vous me posez une question sous entendu
vous êtes un politicien donc vous avez
fait ce que vous venez de faire pour des
histoires électorale non il ya des
enjeux qui dépassent des échéances
électorales
la preuve c'est qu'une organisation
territoriale je vous le rappelle les
régions elles ont été dessinés en 1950
et pour les départements
ça date de la révolution donc ça se fait
pas en fonction des questions
électorales les calculs électoraux ils
sont pas toujours payant sans doute aux
prochaines sénatoriales dans ces
histoires là sait jamais un choix qui
assure à quiconque quelques majorité que
ce soit tout le monde le sait et à
toutes les étapes des changements les
lecteurs ont pu avoir lieu
ceux qui pensent qu'en faisant un
changement et en organisant d'une telle
ou telle manière à voir derrière une
certitude ils se sont même si la
tentation parfois est toujours là enfin
est ce que vous êtes
mais là je le dis à ceux qui nous
écoutent pas ce que bout je me provoque
compact mais non il ya un moment aussi
on peut assumer des choix politiques
stop aussi à cette manière de
décrédibiliser et de ridiculiser une
parole politique des choix sont jamais
faciles à faire bien sûr alors pour
crédibiliser ce projet cette foire est
ce que vous êtes
mesure est bien de chiffrer les
économies escomptées
parce que là le chef de l'état il n'a
pas donné de chiffres par exemple dans
sa tribu d'arriver à la presse régionale
et région parce que il a raison parce
que combien alors dans ce domaine là sur
les chiffres ça sera la mise en oeuvre
de cette réforme qui fera les économies
j'ai vu françois patriat en venant ici à
discuter un peu
sur la bourgogne et la franche-comté eux
ils se sont mis d'accord depuis déjà un
talent terme 12 ya exactement et il l'a
dit moi je sais sur quoi je peux faire
des économies de fonctionnement par
rapport
mais je préfère faire des connaissances
et 12 milliards au niveau national ainsi
on va les dis ça parce qu'à mon
avis c'est pas françois patriat 10 10 10
une dizaine visage je fais confiance à
françois patriat rizières et bien c'est
quelqu'un qui connaît le sujet il a
peut-être pris l'exemple de sa fusion
son choix avec quand je comptais
directoire est extrapolé plus tôt après
tout mettons ça sur la table il ya des
économies potentielles
deuxièmement plus les régions sont
grandes je le dis aussi plus le
fonctionnement qui est un coût fixe et
bien par habitant est faible lorsque les
régions sont grandes et plus il est
élevé
quand les régions soient dites voilà
alors françois hollande peut-il
prétendre se relancer avec cette réforme
et en faire un marqueur de son
quinquennat
je crois que les questions qui sont
posées sur la relance
pour françois hollande dépasse les
éléments de réforme qui peuvent être
proposées ici pour la réforme
territoriale
je n'oublie pas non plus par exemple la
question de la solidarité avec le
vieillissement de la population
je pense que c'est quelque chose qui
s'est inscrit dans quelque chose de plus
large il est nécessaire de réformer pour
la france pour les français pour son
redressement et en même temps c'est au
bout du compte la somme de ce qui aura
été fait qui sera jugé voilà et c'est
comme ça que ça va se faire mais on va
s'y prendre parce qu'il a donc on a vu
l'hostilité de la droite et puis de
quelques grands responsables socialistes
les barres sur la question de la tuerie
de l'été des territoires là si c'était
sur le sur quoi non mais vous m'avez
posé une question sur
adacore blessures sur cette réforme là
aussi c'est un engagement qui est fort
je sais qu'ils posent des problèmes mais
c'est aussi à mesurer à l'aune de ce que
ça doit apporter à la france de manière
globale et on peut pas rester uniquement
campé sur ce qui existe
on le conserve et on bouge pas c'est ça
l'enjeu je pense à chacun et nous on s'y
engagera au niveau de la majorité pour
faire passer pas que ce traité compris
auprès de vos amis députés
bien sûr mon de bretagne non réunissions
la dia l'heure donc la crispation autour
du chef de l'état et les manifeste
surtout après bien sûr les revers
électoraux aux municipales et puis aux
européennes certains évoquent une crise
institutionnelle
je leur ai demandé il ya beaucoup de
commentaires qui sont faits extrêmement
désagréable et quelquefois assez
insupportable donc les institutions
elles sont ce qu'elles sont quand il ya
une cohérence une premier ministre a
très bien dit de la majorité au
parlement
il ya aucune raison qu'on spécule et
qu'on en fasse d'ailleurs une actualité
systématique sur la capacité à aller au
bout de ce qui a été un choix électoral
qui a été fait en mai 2012 et qui doit
conduire le président de la république
sa majorité son premier ministre et son
gouvernement à faire les réformes pour
une seule ambition c'est réformer notre
pays et faire réussir tous les français
la france et il va vous écarter tout
risque institutionnels aujourd'hui les
jeux de manière très claire et sans
risque de déflagration sociale comme
l'aurait dit par exemple nicolas sarkozy
qui parle d'une situation jamais vu sous
la vème république je jeu là oh non plus
jeunes n'accompagnerait pas ses
commentaires en particulier s'ils ont
été faits par nicolas sarkozy puisque je
comprends aussi que derrière tout ça
certains veulent en ajoutant ajoutée et
en rajoute
chacun devrait avoir un tout petit peu
de sens de la responsabilité un plutôt
que de tout le temps en train d'en
rajouter et donc moi là dessus je vais
être très clair il ya un moment où on
dit stop et on fixe son cap et est ce
que françois hollande doit le dire mais
je souhaite invention anéantissant et
cela même c est moi qui le dit
le président de la république il
continue son travail l'exode des
dirigeants du cac 40 s'accélère selon
des chiffres publiés par le monde le
patron de sanofi par exemple il a
déménagé à boston mais de paris cas se
produisent chez danone air liquide
essilor est ce que ces délocalisations
de grands patrons vous inquiète
moi ce qui m'inquiète c'est le fait que
la france se soit désindustrialisé ce
que l'ex patron je prends par exemple gg
du ca d'ailleurs tout à l'heure c'est
après que je n'étais pas au courant mais
le patron de sanofi qui est venu en
france qu'à profiter d'après ce que j'ai
cru comprendre des avantages qui sont
liées à des patrons qui viennent de
l'étranger et qui au bout de cinq ans
perdre ses avantages et il est parti moi
ce qui m'importe c'est que des
entreprises la capacité productive
d'innovation la recherche des grandes
questions stratégiques des centres
décision reste en france
bonds est par ailleurs on se souvient de
françois hollande sur la finance mon
seul adversaire le discours du bourget
aujourd'hui est ce que vous confirmez
que le chef de l'état se mobilisent pour
défendre une très grande institution en
bancaire qui pèse sur le plan mondial
bnp paribas on sait que la banque
française est sous la menace d'une
sanction record de la part des autorités
américaines pour avoir contourné
l'embargo contre l'iran et cuba
le chef de l'état s'implique on a là une
affaire qui concerne une banque et une
banque c'est un outil de financement
d'abord de l'économie et c'est ça qui a
été perdu d'ailleurs pas le système
financier lui-même avec la crise de 2008
ensuite il ya une réglementation
américaine est ce qui a été dit par
laurent fabius et très claires s'il ya
eu des erreurs il doit y avoir des
sanctions mais raisonnable mais elles
doivent être proportionnées parce qu'on
veut pas non plus accepter qu'on bascule
dans une volonté qui serait là de
remettre en cause la l'existence même
d'une banque et d'une grande banque
la vente de sept milliards d'euros quoi
la fresque france 27 linda bon et
françois hollande aura l'occasion de le
dire directement et d'information
titulaire je sais que du côté du
ministère des finances et de tous ceux
qui sont concernés directement vous êtes
mobile y a
une mobilisation et un suivi de ce
dossier alors on va évoquer quand même
l'état de la majorité qui sommes
excusez moi un rêve de plus en plus
nerveuse vous avez parlé de la cohérence
de la majorité il ya un instant ses fans
autant on entend des critiques sur la
méthode des effectifs il ya des demandes
d'inflexion politique
alors avant d'accueillir catherine
perret de la sp donc sur reportage de
samia déchirent sur cette question
réforme territoriale accéléré allégement
fiscal pour les plus modestes
après deux débâcles électorales
successives françois hollande tente de
réagir tout en maintenant le cap
un équilibrisme compliqué qui sème un
vent de panique à l'elysée avec en toile
de fond une question françois hollande
serait t'il en mesure d'être le candidat
socialiste en 2017 cette question qui
émane des rangs même du parti socialiste
inquiète beaucoup l'elysée même si
françois hollande de nature n'est pas
quelqu'un qui montre et qui matérialise
ses angoisses mais on le voit à certains
signaux qui est notamment le fait qu'il
ait décidé de recevoir collectivement
les parlementaires de la majorité
une rencontre pour apaiser l'inquiétude
grandissante dans les rangs des députés
socialistes même chez les fidèles du
chef de l'état il y a aujourd'hui un un
espace de blocage de la part des
français vis-à-vis du président de la
république plus les députés seront en
amont informé des grandes lignes de ces
déclarations plus qu'on les ambassadeurs
pour préparer le peuple à entendre ce
que veut dire le président de la
république
autrement dit la majorité refuse
d'approuver sans mot dire une politique
dictée par un président impopulaire
les frondeurs sont bien décidés à
pousser leur avantage pour réorienter le
cap à gauche
en revenant par exemple sur le gel des
prestations sociales nous ne demandons
pas aux gouvernements un virage à 180
degrés nous lui demandons d'écouter sa
majorité d'écouté des propositions que
nous faisons que nous allons confirmer
au gouvernement dans les prochains jours
des propositions qui vont aussi
permettre de mener ce dialogue avant le
débat au parlement et pendant ce débat
et c'est à partir de cette plateforme
que nous allons nous déterminer dans
quelques semaines les rangs des députés
frondeurs grossistes et personne ne
s'avance aujourd'hui sur le vote des
socialistes sur la loi de programmation
des finances par exemple je trouve qu'il
y a un petit côté velléitaire dans cette
dans cette fronde et j'espère que chacun
reviendra à la raison
sinon bah vous savez ce qui se passe
dans les institutions de la vème
république une dissolution de
l'assemblée nationale très peu probable
du moins pour l'instant
mais la rencontre entre françois
hollande et les députés de sa majorité
prévue mi juin s'annonce tendu voilà
avec nous donc à récupérer de l' agence
france-presse
à vos questions sur le foll oui donc
françois hollande va rencontrer les
parlementaires de sa majorité comme il
l'avait fait une première fois en 2013 à
la maison de l'amérique latine ce que
vous connaissez la date précise je ne
connais pas la date n'a dit autour de mi
juin
on a dit est-ce que c'est pas un peu
trop tard est-ce que le lien n'est-il
pas déjà cassé avec certains socialistes
d'abord jeu par rapport aux reportages
et je vais veiller à ce que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure
iliad espèce de volonté de noircir de
durcir de considérer qu'on est au bord
du gouffre ça c'est répéter tous les
jours je ne parle même pas des mots qui
sont quelquefois utilisé contre le
président de la république par certains
tout ça je l' ai dit tout à l'heure ça
mérite de dire de temps en temps ce top
il ya les français il ya la france
d'abord c'est ça l'enjeu
ensuite je suis parfaitement conscient
que sur les choix qui sont faits il ya
des discussions
elles ont déjà été engagés et le premier
ministre a toujours dit qu'il était là
pour écouter la preuve c'est qu'après
les municipales des choix ont été faits
qui vont dans le sens de ce qui avait
été demandé sur la baisse des impôts est
sûre en particulier la baisse des
cotisations pour les salariés pour
donner du pouvoir d'achat
ça fait partie de la discussion on doit
respecter la majorité mais je demande à
chacun de respecter aussi
et l'exécutif le gouvernement et les
choix du président pour renouer la
confiance avec sa magie
et est ce qu'il doit faire françois
qu'est ce qui doit leur dire le
président et qu'est-ce que je ne suis
pas le président de la république je ne
parle pas à la place du président de la
république je sais une chose je les dis
il faut être capable d'écouter il ya des
choses qui remonte et il faut les
entendre il faut être capable de
maintenir un cap
parce que rien ne serait pire que de
changer tout le temps
deux postures de choix de politique
parce que c'est la france qui est
derrière et pour entraîner un pays il
faut avoir une détermination et une
cohérence ça a été dit ça a été rappelé
c'est ça que je sais mais en même temps
ça n'empêche pas d'avoir cette capacité
d'écouté et de dialogue
alors qu'est ce qu'ils font at il ce
qu'il faut dire qu est ce qu il faut
évoquer je ne me mets pas à la place du
président ira puis je voulais dit mais
c'est ça le cadre dans lequel nous
sommes
elle s'est expliquée et s'expliquer
entre nous c'est ça qui est important
aussi est-ce que ce n'était pas une
erreur de dire dans sa célèbre anaphore
mois président la république je ne
recevrai pas les élus à l'elysée donc si
tu es l'anaphore je vous l'aurais long
et reprise si vous n'aviez pas dit
jusqu'au bout c'était à l'elysée il y
avait des réunions qui était régulière
au tous les parlementaires venus à
l'elysée c'est ça qui était contestée ou
contestable c'est pas ça qui allait
moment vous doit s'expliquer ce a déjà
eu lieu à l'amérique latine
c'était fou je suis plus bon début
d'année 2013 bon bah écoutez il est
normal que temps j'entends y est cette
capacité d'avoir ce lien et cette
discussion est rassuré les troupes
intervention 2017
oui elles sont maintenant beaucoup de
seins beaucoup on entend des socialistes
dire que la candidature de françois
hollande en 2017 n'est pas automatique
d'autres qui parlent de primaires pour
départager
d'autres candidats est ce que françois
hollande at-il est-ce qu'il a une chance
d'être candidat en 2017 politics j'ai
même vu des sondages 3 % de français
mais je voudrais dire que le salon des
26%
je voudrais dire à ceux qui ont fait six
sondages d'ailleurs que j'ai connu les
mêmes sondages et les mêmes sont blessés
3% voulait dire jeu ça me rappelle un
certain nombre de choses
leyrit
icub ridicule de faire ces spéculations
ridicule d'alimenter les commentaires
que vous faites
je ne se quittent pas vous le reprocher
avec ces sondages qui sortent à 3 ans
d'une échéance sans savoir exactement à
temps des cessions des politiques mais
ce qui s'annonçait pas dire que ceux qui
s'expriment politiquement son ou mal
intentionnés
ça peut leur arriver ou ridicule si ils
le font naïvement voilà quand j'entends
de bayrou dit ça ne peut pas durer comme
ça pendant trois ans encore il est
ridicule ah mais je pense que françois
bayrou en disant ça ne peut pas durer
comme ça d'ailleurs quelle est
l'alternative ne sait pas on annonce ça
comme ça parce que c'est une espèce de
formule et ça sert à quoi
si on est responsable politique et qu'on
pense que ça ne peut pas durer c'est
qu'on a quelques idées mais ceux qui
font profession et discours politique
pour uniquement alerté annoncé déclaré
et rien dire derrière ça sert à rien ça
sert à rien voilà c'est ce que je veux
dire et je le dis de manière très
clairement et très fermement
il ya quand même dans les rangs
socialistes d'aidé vous pouvez continuer
si témoin du nom via les îles
le député delcourt non c'est pas comme
ça je connais bien les députés delcourt
jamais il a dit ça le problème
le problème est qu il a dit qu'il avait
mal de levier oui oui on me dit tout guy
delcourt a dit on voudrait être informé
plus tôt pour pouvoir faire comprendre
ce que souhaite
est ce que veut faire le président de la
république qui l'a pas dit c'est la fin
et on va dissoudre l'assemblée
merci claude bartolone interrogé sur les
déclarations de guy delcourt qui dit oui
par certains côtés je ne vais pas
tourner autour du pot il le dit
mais part ça je sais pas si les gens
nous écoutent mais reposer votre
question par sa d'un côté je ne sais pas
si je vais tourner autour du pot car
échelle 2012 tout le monde disait c'est
sur françois hollande va faire deux
quinquennats on veut tous la réussite de
ces deux quinquennats aujourd'hui en
2014 il y avait six amis d'euphorie
lisent ces fonds car il fait la question
se pose il y avait une forme d'euphorie
liée à la presse les élections elle est
aussi d'accord dirais-je ridicule parce
que le ridicule est explicable et il ya
aujourd'hui à dire je le dis je le
répète stop à toutes ces spéculations
on est ne 3 juin 2014
les élections futures c'est en 2017
donc on arrête avec ce petit jeu qui
consiste à demander à des hommes
politiques de commenter ce qui se
passerait en 2017
ils ont pour responsabilité de faire ce
qu'ils ont à faire
et d'expliquer ce qu'ils font alors on
verra si madame et le stop sera entendu
j'ai une petite question le 6 juin
finalement nicolas sarkozy va participer
aux cérémonies de commémoration du
débarquement
oui à l'invitation de françois hollande
c'est sûr que c'est pas la demande de
monsieur poutine
je considère que ancien président de la
république il ya des invités qui sont là
et qui semble paraît tout à fait logique
et je les dis de manière très claire
pour ce qui est de la jada de nicolas
sarkozy il est de sa responsabilité mais
la diplomatie il y en a une et une seule
en france elle est conduite par le
ministre des affaires étrangères le
président de la république
les problèmes de poids je sais que cette
invitation de jeu par commentaire je
trouve qu'il est con on est républicain
oui voilà je voulais revenir à la
majorité dans l'est c'est un sujet alors
que
alors on a vu qu'il y avait donc onze
députés qui s'étaient abstenus de donner
leur conscience à manuel valls
puis 41 qui n'avait pas voulu approuver
le pack de responsabilité est ce que il
ya quand même une partie de la majorité
qui en feront contre l'exécutif parce
que c' est surmontable pour les
prochains textes notamment tous ceux qui
vont mettre en vigueur le pack de
responsabilité mais j'ai bien
parfaitement douter qu'il y avait des
députés qui étaient radicalement
positionner ça fait un peu de temps j'ai
beau me fait rêver oui j'en ai vu je
vous pourriez me charrient qu'évoquer
mais aussi déjà il ya aussi les le
gauche j'ai parfaitement conscience de
ça il ya des gens je leur dis
effectivement on doit être capable entre
nous j'ai connu le parti socialiste jeu
c'est la capacité la propension qu'il y
à a discuté à débattre et ça c'est
acceptable mais chacun doit bien mesurer
la responsabilité qui est la sienne face
je le dis au pays
c'est pas dans une relation entre nous
la c'est avec les français c'est avec la
france la france dans l'europe la france
dans le monde
on est dans une situation qui est
difficile tout le monde doit le rappeler
tout le monde doit en avoir conscience
moi en tant que ministre de
l'agriculture
je suis interpellé tous les jours pour
des problèmes existent dans
l'agroalimentaire et ailleurs en
particulier dans la région de la
bretagne dans une difficulté
tous ces problèmes là c'est pas sous ma
responsabilité qui sont arrivés 1
c'est le fruit d'années est aujourd'hui
de grandes difficultés faut qu'on soit
capable de serrer les coudes faut qu'on
soit capable de trouver des solutions
des choix et des oeufs chose qui
remettent en cause une ligne stratégique
qui a été parfaitement dit est exprimée
par le président de la république
lorsqu'il était en campagne je le
rappelle tegami des primaires qui ont
été qui ont été faites avec 3 millions
de personnes je crois qu'ils sont
nouveauté si on se souvient bien est-ce
qu'à terme il pourra pas y avoir un
risque de dissolution à l'assemblée
nationale mais je ne rentre pas dans ce
débat je vous ai dit là dessus on aura
des débats il ya des débats à voir il
faut respecter le parlement respecter sa
majorité ça c'est indispensable et le
premier ministre a montré qu'il était
capable d'écouter discuter mais il ya
aussi
un moment où il faut que chacun prenne
bien la conscience de ce qu'est la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes et
on s'en sortira ensemble que personne
n'imagine qu'il pourra s'en sortir en
jouant contre la cohérence c'est la
cohérence qui fera qu'on réussira
vêtements c'est pas si françois hollande
parlera avec cette autorité d'avec vous
exprimer lorsqu'il rencontrera les
troupes socialistes sans président là je
parle en tant que prend part au lycée
valeur n'est jamais à la place du
président de la république sur le tandem
manuel valls françois hollande
à chaque intervention le premier
ministre assure de sa loyauté envers le
président de la république
on a quand même l'impression que les
fasse un peu le président de la
république à vous avez cette impression
là eh bien il ya un président de la
république qui a un premier ministre je
les vois je participe à quelques
réunions au conseil des ministres
et je trouve que tout ça fonctionne
parfaitement parfaitement dans la
loyauté pour le premier disque vis-à-vis
du président de la république et dans le
respect du premier ministre et du
gouvernement par le président de
république
dernière question la réforme pénale qui
a été examinée aujourd'hui à partir
d'aujourd'hui à l'assemblée nationale
elle a été repoussée après les
municipales leur gestation depuis deux
ans est ce que c'est le le dernier
combat de christiane taubira
pourquoi vous parler comme ça d'abord
c'est pas un combat et le 2 christiane
taubira même si c'était de la guerre dit
souvent c'est défendre à elle s'investit
elle a montré elle l'a prouvé on est
dans un débat sur des questions
extrêmement importante pour les français
c'est la question en particulier de la
récidive et on le sait c'est pas le
dispositif législatif du aujourd'hui qui
nous prémunit et jeu quand je dis pre
muni d'une augmentation de la récidive
donc il faut qu'on améliore notre
système il faut qu'on le rende plus
efficace c'est ça l'objet du débat c'est
pas de poser la question en se demandant
si sept derniers combats de christiane
taubira et elle mènera ce combat avec
cette idée là cette intention là de
faire en sorte que cette loi améliore
les choses
après la tuerie de bruxelles est ce que
l'urgence n'est pas plutôt de renforcer
l'arsenal contre les jihadistes français
mais l'urgence elle est effectivement de
renforcer notre
sonal vous l'avez dit que ce soit
législatif que ce soit en terme de
mobilisation de l'appareil policier de
la surveillance du renseignement et de
la coopération à l'échelle européenne
bernard cazeneuve s'est exprimé cet
après midi et ce matin devant le conseil
des ministres il a été extrêmement
clairement nous combattrons ces filières
terroristes voilà avec détermination des
filles nues des jamais connu comme le
dit le premier ministre ce qu'il faut
par exemple envisagé est bien de retirer
la nationalité française aux djihadistes
qui rentrent ils ont une autre par
ailleurs mais sur ce sujet il ya des
règles il ya des règles qui sont la
constitution ça ne se fait pas comme ça
oui mais moi mon avis c'est que
aujourd'hui j'ai bien entendu ce qu'a
dit le ministre l'intérieur
il ya un vrai phénomène avec tes danger
derrière et on doit s'organiser
mobiliser l'ensemble de nos moyens se
coordonner à l'échelle européenne pour
éviter que tout ça conduisent à de
problèmes plus graves comme ceux qu'on
accueille voilà l'objectif et s'enrichir
et efficaces existent dans la
constitution un gradé des choix d'une
nationalité pour des raisons qui sont
parfaitement encadré je crois que ça
existe dans la constitution c'est à
exclure dans ces cas mais ça serait ça
c'est pas ça qui résout le problème le
problème c'est que vous avez très bien
posé ses dangers qui existent c'est ce
phénomène et c'est ça qu'il faut
combattre
merci karine juste un mot sur les deux
entrées au gouvernement thierry mandon
et oui car le gars qui remplace madame
fourneyron je croirais à des soucis de
santé malheureusement je lui envoie un
message devrait en de soutien et de
sympathie d'amitié à valérie je sais que
oui elle se remet pas d'aidés d'état de
santé qu'il a connu voilà donc les
revenus et pas comme de l'état il
n'avait pas sa langue dans sa poche
comme porte parole des députés
socialistes avaient dit que c'était un
porte parole je crois du groupe
socialiste qui a le verbe clair et oh
oui je le confirme et carole delga est
une jeune députée du sud-ouest de la
haute-garonne et c'est quelqu'un de
grande qualité
merci à vous si vous avez le verbe est
haut vous avez encore un quart d'heure
pour le montrer cette émission monsieur
les bonnes questions
agriculture puisque perrine tarneaud de
public sénat arrive on va parler
d'agriculture qui est elle aussi
confrontée à la globalisation le poids
de l'aide communautaire aux éleveurs aux
agriculteurs français de la guerre été
rappelé et il faut le dire un durant la
campagne européenne on pourra relever
c'est aussi d'actualité que les régions
ont de plus en plus leur mot à dire sur
la répartition de la pac
le reportage de camilla campus anneaux
des épis de blé sur 300 hectares
l'exploitation de christophe laure au
bourg qu'il tient avec deux amis
l'agriculture ici c'est une passion
transmise de père en fils pour la
dernière fois abbas est très simple
c'est que moi je me souviens j'ai quatre
enfants
sur les quatre enfants il y en a aucun
qui veut rentrer trop difficile de
reprendre les rênes surtout avec la
réforme de la politique agricole commune
christophe va perdre près de 30% de ses
dettes
c'est complètement fou parce
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes soumis à une
loi de marché et c est justement ça nous
servait à moduler les baisses et les os
pour avoir une agriculture à peu près
compétitive en europe et dans le monde
c'est catastrophique mois pour le
secteur économique christophe compte
maintenant sur la région c'est elle qui
pourra distribuer une partie des fonds
de la pac qui qu'on puisse bénéficier je
dirais de ce jour dead pour justement
pour une agriculture qui est spécifique
si on veut continuer à être agriculteur
à 20 kilomètres de paris
demain ça va être compliqué la région se
focalise que sur le lirai sur le sur
l'agriculture biologique mais
malheureusement c'est pas que ça
l'ile-de-france et une multitude
d'agriculture qui a besoin de vivre et
qui a besoin d'amener des produits de
qualité aussi
et ça on l'a oublié le rôle des régions
est en discussions aujourd'hui au sénat
jacques jaouen est venu spécialement de
bretagne
pour ce producteur de lait la pac
représente plus de la moitié de ses
revenus annuels
les régions au coeur de la pac une bonne
nouvelle pour lui le fait de
décentraliser c'est important parce
qu'on se rapproche du terrain en
bretagne c'est nous sommes nombreux
cette petite structure foncière nous la
priorité chez nous c'est la
modernisation des bâtiments d'élevage
c'est pour prendre en compte la
particularité des régions qu'elles sont
associées au processus pour ça va faire
des économies sur la gestion puisqu'il
n'y aura qu'un seul interlocuteur qui va
gérer ces crédits l'a ensuite nous
pourrons mettre en place avec les
organisations représentatives de
l'agriculture une mode de co élaboration
de construction de ces politiques ont
plus proche des territoires et les
agriculteurs une co-construction mais
pas de réelle autonomie des régions
elles devront respecter le cadre fixé
par l'état et bien sûr par bruxelles
voilà donc du gouvernement
est ce que ça veut dire si on suit bien
ce reportage qui va maintenant y avoir
autant de politiques à une école
différente qu'il ya deux régions en
france même si à moins de régions
la question a le mérite de poser avec
une une injonction là aussi qui consiste
à non il ya un choix de contraste et
qu'est ce qu'on a fait aujourd'hui dans
toute cette journée au sénat
c'est justement de discuter d'une
déclaration commune entre les régions et
l'état sur l'application d'une partie
d'un pack un peu de la totalité c'est le
premier pilier c'est à dire le les aides
à l'hectare sont toujours distribuées
par l'état
7 milliards d'euros puis à 1,4 milliard
d'euros qui sont maintenant de la
responsabilité des régions et dans cette
responsabilité des régions
on a fixé par une déclaration des grands
objectifs qu'on allait poursuivre
ensemble et maintenant ces régions qui
sont autorités ne se réunir que les
régions pourront développer à leur
convenance les politiques agricoles en
fonction peut-être de leurs
particularités jeune je viens de dire
qu'il y avait un accord a été passé avec
un cadre national et une application
régionales c'est vrai que chaque région
et la france à cette diversité qui est
une richesse pour son agriculture et
donc les régions de poids adapté mais en
même temps on a fixé des grands
objectifs
un grand plan de modernisation sur ans
deux des bâtiments d'élevage on a fixé
des objectifs sur les compensations de
handicap on a fixé des objectifs communs
sur l'installation de renouvellement des
jeunes on a fixé des objectifs sur les
grands choix sur l'agroécologie et puis
les mesures agro environnementales ont
été décidées et négocier à l'échelle
nationale maintenant ça s'appliquera
l'échelle régionale donc il n'y a pas de
contradiction entre un cadre national
des objectifs qu'on se fixe et qu'on a
négocié avec les régions c'est ça qui
est nouveau je le dis à ce titre là en
tant que mise la lecture et j'en suis
fier parce que je dois être seul
ministre qui a négocié un cadre
d'application d'une grande politique
européenne et nationale avec des régions
pour parler des sujets qui fâchent un
peu plus en matière d'agriculture la
ferme des millevaches qui va dans
l'exploitation va sans doute démarré au
début du mois de juillet si j'ai bien
suivi exactement leur nez dans la somme
sarah lui mais la colère des
agriculteurs
on a vu qu'à rodez vendredi le
conseiller à la culture de françois
hollande a été pris en otage est ce que
vous regrettez que cette ferme des
millevaches et une autorisation
d'ouverture
d'abord il ya plus de 1000 vaches
d'accord c'est 500 vaches et parle
beaucoup on en rajoute toujours sa ses
premiers points et ça c'est cool mais
novaes je vous le dis c'est tout si j'ai
un forme parce que comme moi vous savez
qu'il y aujourd'hui des groupements
d'exploitants agricoles qui font du lait
et qui ont quelquefois 500 pages
d'accord alors à plus tard est ce que
l'évangile
deuxièmement je voudrais dire que par
rapport à ce qu'a dit la confédération
paysanne le porte-parole en particulier
cadix projet du gouvernement et du
ministre de l'agriculture s'est
parfaitement mensonger mon projet moi
justement quand j'ai négocié la
politique agricole commune
c'est développer une agriculture avec
des chefs d'exploitation agriculteurs
paysans éleveurs
c'est tout l'enjeu de la garantie du
statut des grecs
justement pour avoir des exploitants des
agriculteurs des éleveurs qui se
regroupent ça peut faire mille vaches
mais derrière il ya six cinq quatre
exploitants agricoles va vers un modèle
économique
chez soi mais c'est pas forcément
industriel c'est vous trompez mais vous
avez été voir des stabulations qui
existe aujourd'hui sur des bâches qui
n'est pas messi mais ça existe
il ya des choses qui existent qui
s'organise le vrai problème derrière c
est ce que quelqu'un qui a de l'argent
investis pour produire du lait
aujourd'hui est-ce que je peux
l'empêcher non quel est mon problème et
pourquoi c'est pas mon projet c'est son
projet amis et qu'on s'est attaché avec
lui faire respecter toutes les règles en
particulier environnemental c'est pour
ça qu'ils ne ce n'est pas un projet de
millevaches c'est un projet de 500 pages
quel est mon projet à moi c'est d'avoir
des agriculteurs des paysans qui soit à
la tête des exploitations agricoles son
projet à lui c'est j'avais ch'ti et
après je mets des salariés il ya plus
d'agriculteurs c'est ça le problème
et ça c'est pas mon projet mon projet
moi ça consiste à créer dans la loi
d'avenir des groupements d'intérêts
économiques et environnementaux parce
que je veux d avis que moi donc c'est
moins un problème de taille que de
structurer ce que la taille vous en avez
il ya détails qui sont et qui existent
aujourd'hui sont pas au niveau des
millevaches mai en allemagne
vous avez 1000 2000 3000 vaches au
danemark 1000 2000 3000 âge ce n'est pas
le modèle que vous semez j'ai passé le g
de lait je le répète m l'exclure mais
c'est l'or c'est très clair c'est pas
mon modèle c'est pas mon projet d'après
mon projet c'est autre chose
alors que donc je rappelle que là dessus
ce qui a été dit est un mensonge vous
condamnez quand même les dégradations
commises par les militants la
confédération que les jeux gilles caudal
et je l'écouté il ya un projet mais
également il existe il est légal on va
on va te ya je n'ai toujours respecté
les manifestations j'ai toujours dit la
confédération paysanne que je respecte
et leurs positions qui demandait à ce
que mes mails et gradation des ananas et
je n'ai pas été ce n'est pas un projet
mais ce n'est pas la manière dont je
pense qu'on peut porter un débat à
l'échelle nationale voilà c'est très
clair la même manière que d'avoir alors
c'était entre guillemets un parce que
c'était pas une séquestration nos pulls
a aussi l'exagération médiatique le fait
qu'on en rajoute tout le temps je parle
de séquestrer ça s'est passé
chacun chacun était conscient que la
garde à vue qui était celle du
porte-parole d'un confesseur de la
confédération paysanne est un certain
nombre d
heure allait se terminer puisque elle se
termine la matinée n'y a pas de
séquestration mais vous regrettez quand
même qu'on soit en france un tel degré
de crispation que finalement maintenant
le présent l'un public ne peut plus
dépasser sans ce jardin soit envoyé là
je peux pas accepter ce que vous faites
vous êtes en train de me dire passer de
ce problème du village si vous dites à
un tel degré d'exaspération
est ce qu'aujourd'hui un minispace de
placer la ministre peut se déplacer
aujourd'hui en france sans avoir une
manif d'agriculteurs si vous parlez de
l'agriculture est-ce que vous avez vu
partout où je vais j'étais hier à
montpellier des manifestations il ya des
problèmes ça j'en ai parfaitement
conscience faut que j'aie résonne et ça
aussi je m'y emploie mais globalement
peut pas faire par rapport à ça le fait
de dire on peut plus se déplacer quand
même c'est pas vrai c'est pas vrai si je
regarde ce qui s'est passé à caen
président de la république il est bien
allé à quand est ce qu'il ya eu des
manifestations
donc cessons de faire ces amalgames pour
faire des commentaires
il ya des réalités j'accepte tout à fait
des remarques
mais comment ces deux d'en rajouter pas
faut quand même que chacun ça vaut pour
les politiques
ça vaut aussi pour les journalistes on
est un peu de sens de la responsabilité
et à vous pour les manifestants je les
lis je les dis j'étais pas d'accord avec
la manière je serais passé on est loin
quand même de la société apaisée
ça c'est une réalité non c'est une
réelle alors ça je suis très fragile les
très fragile et fera chine je le dis je
le répète elle est fragile donc société
jouit parce que manger des difficultés
sont là j'en prend parfaitement
conscience et les votes qui se sont
exprimés sont là pour révéler pas même
s'il n'avait pas besoin d'aller faire
ses votes pour certains pour qu'on en
prenne conscience
c'est une société fragile donc il faut
qu'on soit absolument responsabilités ça
peut mener au pire parfois mais il faut
jamais anticipé le pire
faux le coup jurés c'est ça le problème
parce que si chacun est là tous les
jours pour annoncer le pire
peut-être qu'il va arriver et bien la
responsabilité c'est d'éviter le pire
c'est ça d'ailleurs c'est une belle
manière de définir la responsabilité
politique
est ce que vous êtes en vieux quand même
à stéphane le foll
voir un petit peu ce qui se passe en
italie de voir toutes les réformes mises
en oeuvre par matteo renzi avec
finalement la popularité qui
accompagnent ces mesures mises en place
en italie sien et qui permet de
terrasser le populisme mais oui je suis
envieux bien sûr tous les résultats qui
sont les mairies n'ont que l'italie
renzi arrive je ne sais pas ce que sera
sa situation dans un an ou deux ans il
est un moment où je vous le rappelle
quand même
berlusconi la droite au a disparu que en
phase donc il y a ceux pp grillon voilà
nous en face on a une situation
politique qu'on connaît on a un front
national on a les difficultés qu'il faut
qu'on règle on a un pays qui n'est pas
l'italie qui empêche le gouvernement
actuel de crise mais vous parlez de
résultats vous dites que vous êtes
satisfait oui je regarde les résultats
de rennes dit j'aurais préféré faire 42%
oui je vous le dit bon voilà on me pose
les questions j'y réponds non aline en
italien on a connu me disent qu'à des
sites et très vite sans hésitation
c'était quand même temps qui est arrivé
qui a baissé les impôts étaient six mois
ci a nettement mieux le travail et
surtout ce qui est important c'est qu'il
va engager
il va s'engager sur la présence de
l'europe
et là les engagements j'ai bien regardé
sur les questions sur la croissance
c'est un atout c'est une discussion
qu'on doit avoir
et là c'est le changement qui a été
rappelé et souhaitée par le président de
la république françois rebsamen vient
d'annoncer qu'il y aura deux fois plus
de contrats d'avenir prévue pour 2014
plus 95000 si j'ai bien suivi ça vient
d'être annoncée ça veut dire que
finalement il n'ya que la solution des
contrats aidés pour gérer trouver des
solutions à la somme annoncée il ya les
deux chats la question des contrats et
de la politique publique emplois
d'avenir dans le secteur non marchand
dans secteur marchand il vaut mieux que
les jeunes soient au travail et une
formation que de rester au chômage
c'est très important et je rappelle
quand même si le gym et prolongeant les
problèmes si les chiffres sont pas bons
sur le chômage des jeunes ces -3 8%
ça c'est un point mais le chômage reste
le la plaie qu'il faut qu'on
cicatrise et donc on a deux jouty la
bonite république et je vous le rappelle
quand même que vous oubliez le pacte de
responsabilité de solidarité
le pack de responsabilité j'étais hier à
montpellier je l'expliquais à des
acteurs économiques c'est plus de 30
milliards d'euros qui sont là ni pour
soutenir l'activité l'investissement et
l'embauchent pour les entreprises 30
milliards d'euros plus que ça avec ce
qui assure un certain nombre de mesures
fiscales c'est plus de 30 milliards
d'euros
c'est donc un choix stratégique c'est et
la politique publique d'emploi et la
capacité qu'ont à redresser notre
économie nos entreprises pour qu'elles
en rouge
stéphane le foll vous accompagnez depuis
très longtemps françois hollande dans
quel état d'esprit vous vous sentez vous
aujourd'hui on voit assez combatif
non mais moi j'ai toujours su l'info je
suis combatif
j'étais un sportif amateur je n'ai pas
eu de carrière professionnelle mais
c'est vrai je suis quelqu'un qui se bat
se bat parce que cette pression négative
moi je résiste j'ai fait tout pour faire
en sorte de transmettre de l'énergie je
vois trop de jean françois hollande on
n'en joue pas à françois hollande
j'ai suffisamment à faire et j'ai
françois hollande de ce côté là j'ai
connu des périodes difficiles
j'en ai connu après je sais sa capacité
à exister et à se redresser et à faire
face merci beaucoup dans les cas je note
que vous avez dit que les résultats sur
le chômage ne sont pas bons c'est un
discours qu'on entend brutt sauf pour
les jeunes avaient vous allez génial
mais j'ai continué sont pas bons merci
merci beaucoup fait rire ministres du
gouvernement d'avoir été avec nous ne
sommes pas très vite à tous